[Music]
food companies work hard to ensure their
products are safe for allergic consumers
they often use the same production line
for different products or they share
facilities with other companies
so it's essential that they test for the
unintentional presence of food allergens
even after rigorous cleaning
these tests and their results can vary
considerably between laboratories
therefore companies take the extra
precaution of including warnings on
labels indicating that products may
contain traces of other allergenic
ingredients
could we help companies to avoid
overusing these warnings on labels by
increasing their confidence in allergen
tests and in turn give allergic
consumers more choice in the future
we have been working on a system to test
and produce reliable and comparable data
across thousands of laboratories
we started by developing a reference
method to accurately assess the total
content of milk protein in a cookie with
the same protocol for all manufacturers
we would guarantee comparable results
we chose milk because allergy to cow's
milk is still one of the most common
food allergies in early childhood and
can persist through adult life
we are developing the world's first
certified reference material for the
detection of total milk protein in
processed food
when released this certified reference
material will help food companies and
official control laboratories to
calibrate their instruments
and with better calibration they will
obtain more precise measurements with
more certainty about the data gathered
and to make our efforts known we
establish the european network of food
allergen detection laboratories which
will share the knowledge across all eu
member states
the european commissioner for health and
food safety has referred our work to the
european parliament as an important
contribution
it will help curb the proliferation of
labels
while giving allergic consumers more
choices in full confidence
every day the joint research center
works to ensure that the data produced
across europe is comparable
helping consumers to be confident in the
well-informed choices they make find out
more on our website